[Musique]
dernier
oui
à
voilà
[Musique]
oui mais
[Applaudissements]
ça
mais le drame ironisant
alors c'est vrai la consommer la
question c'est y ce qu'elle a le masque
évidemment un saut à sa grande soeur on
veut rien révéler même bien sûr car si
vous avez révélé quoi la dernière qu'on
vienne me voir on la connaît elle était
inversée qui a fallu encore non non on a
du sens et des amis quand même non non
non aux états unis j'ai une question
intéressante envie de savoir la fin des
films à magali moi j'ai tant est qu'on
ne dira pas cette alliance et si on
regarde et il fait les policiers feront
pas si jamais la samare qui est très
bien c'est à magali on sait pas si c'est
vrai ou faux mais ce problème fonctionne
sur sa sur le fenua blessures nous ont
dit c'est boccolini c'est maradona
ouais c'est sûr ils passent carla bruni
machin va nous amène à quoi quand même
bien sûr c'est pas une personne en
fauteuil merci martin c'est à dire vrai
bonne remarque c'est vrai qu'on aurait
pu peut-être pipi louer ou alors ils
sont très forts auraient décidé
d'annoncer tous deux handicaps dans le
programme on sait par être conséquent
alors concernant les secrets de
fabrication est ce que vous avez
remarqué comment ça se déroule et tout
ça sur vous avez regardé attentivement
oui par exemple le reveal moment où on
vous dit qu'ils le masque insisté au
tournage et on leur mettait dix ont un
écran vert sur lequel était incrusté
ensuite les différentes personnes alors
demandé de faire qui peut la révélation
waouh de jouer l'excitation fait
décathlon quelques salles ont fait
défaut je vais vous dire clairement ce
que va dire maxime gagné en fait leur
évite se fait sans public mes racines
c'est ça épices et c'est plus un oui et
le public à la photo de quelqu'un mais
ce n'est pas la vraie personnellement
surpris mais alors là bas personne
la personne qui sait ferrer qui s'est
fait démasquer six puis dix ans la
semaine dernière c'est on sent bien
quand même que dans le reveal sais pas
qui c'est on sent bien qu'il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas une révélation
ils sont surpris non pas de la personne
mais quel est son nom en fait
mais si c'est vrai aussi
c'est ahurissant c'est surtout autour de
soi
allez
[Musique]
wee aa
le champion
il a des pouvoirs
m
mal
accor de tous
grand lille se séparaient qui aurait
touché un cachet entre 15000 et 20000
euros pour la prestation pour deux jours
un pour enregistrer la chanson et de
dons pour être sur plateau et c'est le
magazine public qui le révèle alors on
avait donné les cachets je considère a
montré qu'elle me dit que ça allait de
20 mille a beaucoup plus à beaucoup plus
plus de 100000 euros même sa naissance
avait des personnes était que l'on cite
en plus alors sans révéler quoi que ce
soit parce que je ne suis pas au courant
donc je le dis clairement
sauf que j'ai regardé l'émission parce
que j'avoue que ça m'a intéressé je veux
c'est plutôt bien fait alors j'avoue
aussi que marie josé pérec ça a été un
peu une déception
[Musique]
elle est championne mais elle rate ce
championnat vie bien sûr j'étais un peu
déçu en revanche je sens qu'il ya du lio
qui est du marc lavoine elle est là la
connerie qu'ils ont faite f1 parce
qu'ils ont et ils ont été très forts sur
les jeunes et un jeune qui a 15 ans ou
qu'à 20 ans il connaît pas donc c'est
peut-être que ce sera tout les 6
millions qui étaient là peut-être son
hilarant simple un foutu de ma gueule za
on nous annonce des noms de ouf
au final on connaît même pas la meuf est
bien lisse même camille combal on
s'irrite maintenant il a comme elle
ternit l'image regarde
tout est exagéré et mamie rajoute des
applaudissements et des cris ça c'est
pénible à chaque fois ils font ça vous
savez que dans d'autres pays
ça se fait en direct en en allemagne par
exemple et des pays où c'est en direct
au système on sent vraiment la chanson
là ils sont quasiment tous en playback
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs bien il ya un
playback qui est prêt il chante quand
même en direct en fait en en public et
en direct parlement il ya un bail à un
playback parce que c'est compliqué
techniquement il ya des frottements de
micros mélenchon si on peut mettre
jusqu'à un arrêt sur image la licorne
qui chante avec 2 micros qui est donc
dans la zola comme ça jusque là en fait
la nique aux comptes n'ont en fait le
halal micro dans l'oeil en fait un ami
pour lui dire que faut mettre le micro
c'est de bach à 100% mans il ya les
versions enfin la production dit qu'il
ya eu des versions mais après ça je me
situe mise sur le costume qui est super
jolie tu peux te sacrifier le cdj la
voie du dialogue mais on s'en fout que
ce soft plus ancien c'est d'entendre la
chanson du film - visuel du coach et moi
qu'est ce qui fut un élève l'île eglin
extraordinaire je m'en fous moi que ce
soit dans les bacs la chanson et
costumes jeunesse ou été sérieux quand
tu dis que tu aimes négocié lors que moi
que ça angoisse de voir marie josé pérec
goldorak
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
apparemment je suis pas du tout le grand
public parce qu'il y avait 6 6 millions
personnes donc c'est énorme et moi pour
moi ça va lâcher c'est simplement parce
qu'il a eu une promotion extraordinaire
de la part de tf1
ils ont martelé le programme et les
gencives y mets moi-même ça on peut pas
dire l'effet de curiosité et surtout
pardon mais expliquez moi une chose
peut-être vous allez pouvoir éclairer
mais comment est-ce que tf1 nous en veut
parce que les membres du jury
excusez moi j'ai rien contre elle mais
entre un goon quèbre moelleux kev adams
jeu jarry et alessandra sublet ça ça
fait rêver ça prend pas moi je le trouve
bizarre c'est qu'ils balancent des noms
dont 11 bien évidemment quand même il
n'y croit pas ça va péter à
oui mais voilà licorne jeu j'optais
plutôt pour sandrine quétier
il m'écoute et nous nous verrons ça il
ya beaucoup de rumeurs sur sa alors
d'haneda dernières infos sur sur le
programme non on n'a pas une petite info
matin maxime dernières informations oui
c'était extrêmement sécurisé des zones
d'accès ont été mises en place
évidemment les gens ont signé des
contrats de confidentialité extrêmement
serré là dessus et puis exploser des
attentes en matière d'audience dans le
rap n 58 % des jeunes
regardez cette mission 58% c'est du
jamais vu depuis très bonne nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
des 1000 euros les 30 secondes ça
rapporte et quand même 4 millions six
cent cinquante mille euros c'est pour se
faire une idée aux états unis il ya
actuellement même moment il ya ça se
passe aux etats unis aussi en direct est
la seule qui a été révélé et tori
spelling esteli l'actrice de beverly
hills et la dernière s'écaille gêneurs
ce n'est quand même pas mal pas mal et
moment